so you did this
i did this shot i would say we're kind
of the actors of 3d animation
if you look at it you go oh that feels
wrong
hey everybody welcome back to our third
ever episode
of animators react we're here with alex
snow who is a 3d animator currently
working at dreamworks but he's been all
over the industry alex tell us a little
bit about what you do
i'm mainly focused on character
animation i would say we're kind of the
actors of
the pipeline the pipeline for 3d
animation
is from script to storyboard into layout
which is focused more on cameras and
character placement not necessarily the
acting and so when it gets to us
we're really focused on characters
specifically so each character kind of
has limitations which will guide your
performance a little bit
it's more like puppeteering than
traditional animation you're really
manipulating
a rig which is all the controls inside
the skeletal system of every character
oh very cool what kind of projects have
you worked on
cloudy with a chance of meatballs too
amazing spider-man one and two
frozen two lots of twos
so we've got a bunch of clips and you
provided a bunch of clips so why don't
we jump in and take a look and you can
give us some insight from an animator's
eye
so this was my first time animating any
song
ever my role was just a couple shots
kind of in the middle
like all these projects it takes an army
to make them and the team was really
awesome especially on this
song like why we're in this dark
enchanted wood
this shot when the thorns was just him
going through
and he's just singing and happy and i
thought it would be funny if he's kind
of
dancing through it and avoiding just
narrowly avoiding it especially because
he's olaf like he can even jump and
separate and
dodge in fun ways so i really wanted the
choreography to kind of flow through
there
so there's no like dance choreographer
in these movies that's you guys
basically just
coming up with your best stuff off the
top of your head yeah that's just me
dancing in a room of mirrors
to kind of figure it out for someone
like olaf he's probably not the best
dancer
my choreography is just fine but if i
were to do someone who's
trained in ballet my performance is only
going to be so good
movies with actual dancing or or
fighting
they'll bring in choreographers and
sometimes it's just to get a general
idea and sometimes it's like do this
frame refrain
it used to be this like show the shadow
and then it pulled out to reveal olaf
so i kind of had this idea of instead of
revealing olaf like that with a pullback
just to kind of let olaf come in and
that would kind of make his shadow
go from this monster into and it's like
he's so far away that it's deformed and
there might be trees there might be this
or that and it kind of just
melds into the olaf you you know kurt
klein actually animated that in 2d
until it morphs into olaf and then it's
a second olaf with the copied animation
just with a shader of black but bert did
an awesome job on that and the team
after us
with effects and lighting and everything
really made it come to life or they just
take it
way to the next level you should see
what this looks like in like a non-lit
version like i stuck the wolf extra wolf
teeth
into an extra olaf and
and so i could get the shape of that
mouth so that's an olaf head in the
background
yeah i like that one has like an olaf
chin with like
a little smile but i knew you wouldn't
see it and and all that matters again is
that last image and
i knew the departments after me would
would knock it out of the park with the
eyes and everything kind of coming
together
it's great to know that just like in
like actual filmmaking just
behind the curtain and just behind that
set piece is as much
janky gaff tape and wires as it is in
like real life oh yeah
the characters i like the best are kind
of these characters with restrictions
so like olaf and baymax are great
examples like olaf can't
bend his arms because it maintains that
idea of their sticks
but it also gives him this kind of
innocent baby kind of feel
and and it's so charming you can
bend just a little bit to get that flow
especially through the fingertips but it
was always kind of a rule that you try
not to see it that's interesting like
there's not like there's no like clear
elbows
anytime
a little bit but of course like all the
jokes and storyboards are like
like the most bent arms and then you're
like and then he touches his head and
you're like
okay the ability to keep a character
on model that's probably the biggest
thing like new animators struggle with
what do you mean by on model
like if you look at um beauty and the
beast for example there's one shot in
particular the shot of beast eating soup
his neck is is maintaining its length
even though his head is turned like
nothing's really connected his eyes are
going who knows where
if you look at it you go oh that feels
wrong or that feels weird you're saying
when squidward gets
really handsome that's off model yeah
but for a joke exactly
it's on purpose got you yeah okay for 3d
animation
normally you have what's called a pose
library a pose library is basically
a tool where you can just see all the
different poses so
the character supervisor on on frozen
two with tren corey
they'll put together a page of all the
expressions that you can think of that
you're going to use the most often
you're very rarely on a film like this
just clicking and plugging it in
it's usually some sort of blend to get
there a little smoother and faster and
without breaking stuff
when i saw this in the storyboards i was
like i have to have that shot please
give me a shot i was so lucky and
thankful to get it
and the original boards this was much
more just like
a panicky it's kind of just all rolling
and i thought
i think it should be stand still for a
moment just having this moment of olaf
realizing like oh this is weird
at the same time like the audience is
like what i've never seen that before
and then it's like oh go it's like all
about the rhythm when he's running with
those little stick arm legs
it's amazing it's it's this like ramp up
of speed that dude
and so you get that rhythm that speed up
in 2d
you really used multiples or what's
called smear frames as a replacement for
motion blur because you didn't have
after effects and all that stuff right i
wanted to get that feel of just quick
quick quick
so what i did was i thought multiples
would be helpful
in pushing that that shape language of
like going from here to here
over a faster period of time that's
super cool it's crazy
how much 2d animation principles are
coming into play in this shot
everything from like warping the pupils
to like not even having him
look at the wolf just you know implying
that he's looking at the wolf through
basic cartooning
smearing multiples all these things like
it's all very much
taking your 3d tool set but
acknowledging that you're delivering a
2d image
and and actually delivering a 2d image i
think that's the big difference between
something like disney animation
dreamworks animation pixar animation
is this really focused appeal
where you're thinking about each frame
like the drawing but
yeah this was like a dream come true
shot this is like my favorite thing i've
ever done
hey if you guys have enjoying these
animators react episodes please
subscribe we really love doing these if
we get 8 000 subscribers
clinton here is going to watch
all the avengers films i'll do it i'll
put them on
all the tvs i'll watch them at one time
i'll sit there and i'll really take them
in i'll really take them in
a question that's a weird question
you ever heard that like old disney
movies are slipping in like
penises here and there
like is that true they definitely did
replace the cover
of i think little mermaid yeah a little
mermaid so someone thought it was close
enough
but in new movies there's none of i mean
as far as i know
you can sneak easter eggs in sometimes
especially
if you ask big hero 6 probably had the
most easter eggs of any
movie i've seen or worked on the easter
eggs that i
do personally tend to be more like from
life
so like on smurfs like i have a dance
that like my wife used to always do and
i'd make fun of her and so that was like
smurfette was dancing like her so i get
reference from my kids all the time just
or or ideas from them or someone you see
on the street especially in la
and if you consider that an easter egg
that's everywhere
you did this i did this shot this scene
is cool man i really like how this is
put together
so this is a weird and crazy shot so at
the time the only animated time lapse
was on wreck-it ralph and it's just a
straightforward time lapse of like the
arcade
new machines coming in and people
playing and there's kind of smears of
like characters moving across
but with this time lapse it was
different because it had to tell
a story of him being in the garage
figuring out what he's going to build
for this competition
i wanted to capture this idea of like
the team and the family it was important
to john lasseter at the time
he only had two notes before i started
he wanted to see the team
and he wanted to see a hero sleep that
was it
and it was like go every frame is
animated or opposed
i try to have as many like life moments
in here like
playing with mochi and sometimes mochi's
just hanging around and tadashi his big
brother comes and like sits and watch tv
in the back
and so i'm really faking time lapse here
because that's not how they work
like he's hanging out with a group in
the back it's like did they only move
like this
they're eating pizza for two hours like
it doesn't make sense when you think
about it but when you're seeing these
moments like i just try to have him move
or
shift enough that you're like oh he's at
that desk and he's working
i think i did this in like two weeks um
and so
yeah that's such a cool thing it was
crazy definitely one of the things i'm
most proud
of and it was super educational what
program are you using
at disney we're using maya but it has
proprietary
tools and things like that i'd love to
come back and talk about animation some
more specifically anime if you guys have
any good
and horrible examples i'd love for you
guys to send them to these guys
and i'll hop on back and and talk your
ear off
this is incredibly bad but good this
isn't the lion king
it's it's a remake of the lion king and
it's
fantastic this is this is great
oh my god
the king
you're welcome and so you're seeing
things that are like just moving on
their own like heads body stretching is
like an accordion one second he's stiff
on another
the there's no simulation the jaw is
just kind of moving
dude i love this way he has like anybody
enter the scene it's always like head
first and then the rest of the body
i also love that the background is just
like ms paint yeah
yeah he also made an elsa singing let it
go one that's equally as fantastic
it's somewhere between frozen rick and
morty
that's her she changes her hair
so that's horrible in all the best ways
i mean this is not good
animation as far as like everything
we've talked about that makes animation
good or believable or specific
yeah but it's successful for humor it's
just for humor
it's it's a parody like doodlebob yeah
ladies and gentlemen i have a special
announcement for you the corridor
digital store has been restocked with
brand new designs from some of your
favorite videos
and other things we've done we have the
m6h magnum from halo
one of the best weapons in the game
perhaps one of the best weapons in all
video games
here broken down for you in a part by
part layout hawaiian designs are back in
this is one of our most demanded genres
of clothing to bring back
do not miss out on that for all the dads
in your life
a boss town dynamic shirt with just
robot the dog out nature
throw out the dog just living life
having a good time on the beach together
like buddies
this hat which i've been wearing
exclusively for myself for over half of
the year
we literally had like a crate of these
sitting on a boat and wuhan
back when the virus broke out and
they've been sitting on that barge
ever since it's finally available
that's right this one's going to stop
like a minute so
good luck just a heads up if you are a
member of the corridor digital.com
website
you get 15 off so you're planning on a
big order you can get a membership and
it'll
pretty much pay for itself you can find
all that and more at the corridor
digital store corridor digital dot store
or
somewhere in the link below go check it
out i hope all of you have had a
wonderful thanksgiving
i am thankful for all of you watching
our videos and supporting us we really
appreciate it here at corridor
all right i'll leave you with that
corridordigital.store
alex thank you so much for joining us on
this show it was really cool to hear
your insights you know all the stuff
you're talking about like with movement
like that applies to all the action
cinematography that we do that even
applies just to regular
old-fashioned filmmaking and acting if
we want to see any more of your work or
follow anything that you do is there any
way to follow you online instagram is
snowmation
and it's starting up a new a new one
doubleplus productions
well thank you so much alex really
appreciate you coming out awesome being
here